you know for a little while it was
mostly a radical republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene who
was comparing things to the holocaust
equating things to the nazis
raising other comparisons to world war
ii it's now just becoming very
widespread on the american right and it
has a lot to do with vaccines we're
going to look at a few clips here is
david brody who used to be a regular
panelist on meet the press
he was on his show i guess he has a show
now water cooler on real america's voice
i don't know i don't even know what that
means
he is again talking about nazis and
nuremberg codes when it comes to
vaccination take a listen violation of
federal law
so why well because it would violate a
little thing called the nuremberg code
code mentioned on the fda website not
pizzagate.com or conspiracy.net the
nuremberg code emphasizes that people
cannot be forced to take experimental
drugs without their full consent now
interesting interestingly here the term
nuremberg code originated in 1947
germany during the nuremberg trials
where of course nazi doctors attempted
to excuse the inhumane deadly
experiments that they conducted on
concentration camp prisoners by claiming
that there were no explicit rules
governing medical research on human
beings in germany during that period but
you're probably thinking well hey hold
on that's nazi germany and nurburg code
or or not the u.s government would never
admit it yeah so so the implication is
that having a requirement in order to
work at certain places or go to certain
schools or whatever the case may be
that that's equivalent of a phase three
trial a fate widely phased three trial
uh vaccine is similar to nazi medical
experimentation on jews now that sounds
sort of crazy because it is
so then when he brings on his guest matt
staver he sort of says you know we're
we're not literally saying that but so
you kind of are dude take a listen well
you know it's interesting you say the
siren should go off and you're
absolutely right unfortunately the
sirens are going off the other way the
vaccinated or excuse me the unvaccinated
in this country are being demonized uh
there's discriminatory stuff going on
out there i i'm curious as it relates to
the legal issues here regarding the
nuremberg code i mean if it's under
experimental use uh
what does that mean legally in terms of
now even that when they say what e it
just so happens that experiment and
emergency both start with the letter e
and eua is an emergency use
authorization it's not an experimental
use authorization that's that's another
deliberate deception of this going up
the uh legal food chain what what could
happen here
well even before you get to the
nuremberg code you have the emergency
use authorization law it clearly says
that you have the quote option to accept
or refuse close quote that's repeated in
the fact sheet required by the fda and
it's also mentioned many times by the
fda so that's the end of story you have
the option to refuse
when it's in the eua and it's an eoa
specifically designated so by the fda
now do you guys believe that when you
know we're somewhere between two and
five weeks from at least the pfizer
vaccine given given permanent approval
by the fda
do you think that when that happens
they'll just say oh now we're good now
go and get vaccinated of course not
they're just going to come up with
something else
and federal law in the nuremberg code
the very first point says that the
voluntary consent of the human subject
is absolutely essential there should be
no duress no deception no pressure and
we're doing exactly the opposite we are
violating federal law we're violating
the nuremberg code all of these will be
brought into court to raise these issues
because we are repeating this is the
tragic
part of this we're repeating the dark
history of nazi germany and we're not
learning the lessons that the nuremberg
you know we're really not matt code and
those nazi experiments should have
taught this generation so you're liking
it to that time period we talked about
that in the monologue and we want to be
clear i guess we have to do the
disclaimer about the holocaust and jews
we're not talking about that right i
begrudgingly have to mention we're not
really talking about the holocaust
except we are because we're saying that
a required vaccine after phase three
trials
uh violates the nuremberg codes just
like the nazis did during their medical
experiments it's crazy this is where
they're now uh is this the plane where
they now exist here's one more example
newsmax guest pastor brian gibson
yeah says that vaccinations
that was actually an accident uh newsmax
guest uh pastor brian gibson says
vaccination is going to provide a
framework for future genocide yeah
what do you make of that pastor yeah
yeah they're playing uh this comes
straight out of the marxist handbook
right you try to set as many different
groups against each other as you can in
a nation to weaken it tear it apart and
rebuild it in the image you want uh at
first in america it was it was racial
tension black versus white now we're
moving from vaccinated to the
unvaccinated and i'll tell you it's
scary because whenever you see guys
saying you see leaders saying you can go
to the gym if you have the vaccination
you see the president talking about the
problem that is the unvaccinated these
things have played out before in history
he's sort of alluding to
saying the unvaccinated in a pejorative
way
is like when the nazis started saying
the jews he
that if you're not making the connection
this is the analogy he's making and then
he actually just straight up says it
where do you take a certain group of
people and demonize them yeah and i'll
tell you what it is it's a framework for
animosity between two groups at best at
worst it's a framework for a future
genocide so there it is just like the
jews started to be demonized
by the nazis the unvaccinated are
starting to be demonized by the
vaccinated i guess and by joe biden uh
that we we are in real real serious
trouble here as a country my friends if
these narratives become the prevailing
narrative so once we get that fda
approval
let's see how many of them go out and
get vaccinated it won't be quote
experimental anymore as they like to say
let's see how many of them go out and
get vaccinated at that point in time let
me know your thoughts uh on twitter you
can find me at deepakman and remember
that we are now just about 10 days away
from the david pakman show 16th
anniversary on that day august 16th you
can get
an insanely discounted david pakman show
membership i would love for you to do
that and support the program if you want
to be notified on august 16th of how to
do that just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video